[Music]
the hardest part about being a maid here
is a can't go home you live here and
gonna go in and go eat supper they're
gonna go to bed and don't get up do it
again tomorrow
in prison it is the head warden who is
responsible for every critical decision
prison is in better shape every year
it's beautiful place the beautiful prism
you know when you look out across who
would ever think you'd say a beautiful
rhythm for over a decade at Angola that
roll has belonged to warden burl Kane
it's like a big plantation in days young
but we hate to call it that in a way but
the county years because we have the you
know the it's inmate improve it cost
about $10,000 a day to feed the people
dango every day Sun comes up but Kemp
I'll not open any cash register by the
food to feed Angola I told that paper
bill a tango is fifty one thousand
dollars a year for toilet paper okay did
it take for y'all holding none of his
responsibilities carried greater
consequence than the oversight of
executions did you find a vein with him
with that much pressure on him there had
been six executions during warden Kane's
tenure there would be Debra : old age
and illness the real concerns of men
with life sentences have caused the
deaths of 412 others in the same period
okay you take it
record Merry Christmas Union family okay
buddy alright number time yeah well you
know at 75 years I've been locked up 25
I'm eligible for parole inaudible now
yes I don't know okay you're fifty to go
if you don't you get Andre yeah